.
Ich habe einfach bemerkt,
dass mir mein Hals
seit einer Weile nicht mehr gefällt.
Dass er einfach zu viel Haut hat.
Ich werde dieses Jahr 50 und finde,
das ist ein guter Zeitpunkt.
Auf der Strasse würden Sie nie
denken, dass wir Spitzenreiter
bei der Anzahl
ästhetischer Behandlungen sind,
bezogen auf die Bevölkerung.
Als ich mit Botox aufhörte,
musste ich sagen,
Lebendigkeit im Gesicht
ist mir viel wichtiger
als irgendwelche Falten.
Was ist das Ziel des Lebens?
Eine schöne Visage
oder ein gelebtes Leben?
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Das ist eben der Hals,
der mich stört.
Sehr oft halte ich meine Hand
so unters Kinn.
Dann schaue ich mich mit dem Spiegel
so von der Seite an.
Dann denke ich:
"Es wäre so schön, wenn es so wäre."
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Sie machen etwas hin, dann
wieder weg und dann doch wieder hin.
Wie in Pfäffikon, dort haben
sie eine Strasse verbarrikadiert,
damit sie nur noch Einbahn ist.
Zuerst dachte ich,
das ist einfach das normale Altern,
das jeder Mensch durchmacht.
Niemand wird im Alter schöner.
Ich kenne niemanden.
Aber ich dann fand ich,
dass es doch immer etwas mehr wird.
Im letzten Jahr, das darf ich sagen,
sah ich eine Frau, die den Eingriff
in der Klinik machen liess,
in die ich gehen werde.
Und das hat mich überzeugt,
dass ich das auch will.
Mir gefällt es,
und sie sieht so viel schöner aus.
Sie hatte einen sog. Trutenhals.
Zum ersten Mal im Leben wurde ich
mit diesem Wort konfrontiert.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass man das so nennt.
Aber wenn man sich überlegt,
hat das Tier genau diesen Hals.
Ich zähle mich
zu den Ästhetikerinnen.
Aber ich bin nicht jemand, der
sich ständig mit Schminken befasst.
Gar nicht. Ich bin eigentlich
sehr einfach und ...
Natürlich.
- Ja.
Und wenn sie sich etwas
in den Kopf gesetzt hat,
dann muss das gemacht werden.
Damit muss man sich abfinden.
Aber es ist gut so.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Dass der Hals so runterhängt,
passt nicht,
weil ich mich
wirklich nicht so alt fühle,
wie ich es auf dem Papier bin.
Interessant ist ja, dass viele
diese Operationen damit begründen,
dass sie ihre Identität
in Übereinstimmung bringen -
so wie sie sich innerlich fühlen,
wollen sie äusserlich aussehen.
Aber es findet eigentlich eine
unglaubliche Konformierung statt.
Man passt sich immer mehr ...
... einem Bild an, das gesamt-
gesellschaftlich vorgegeben ist.
Es führt nicht zu einer
grösseren Individualisierung,
sondern vielmehr zu einer Anpassung.
Frau Müller, ich begrüsse Sie.
Sie dürfen mit mir kommen.
Sehr gerne.
So bleiben, nicht mehr bewegen.
So, jetzt blitzt es einmal.
Wir haben ein 3-D-Bild gemacht,
damit wir uns das
zusammen anschauen können.
Das hier stört Sie.
- Genau.
Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten,
das zu korrigieren.
Wobei man immer
den Grad der Erschlaffung,
also wie viel sich schon
verändert hat, berücksichtigen muss.
Bei Ihnen sind wir in der Situation,
dass wir das
nur noch operativ lösen können.
Wir fangen an der Haarlinie an,
führen den Schnitt
an der Ohrmuschel entlang.
Hier zeichne ich nur Punkte,
denn der Schnitt
führt hinter dem Knorpel entlang.
Dann um das Ohrläppchen,
hinter dem Ohr hoch.
Und noch ein kleines Stück
an der Haargrenze entlang.
Wenn wir das geöffnet haben,
können wir in dieser Zone
die Haut anheben.
Dann können wir in das
Unterhautgewebe, das uns Halt gibt,
solche Abnäher reinmachen.
Dadurch kriegen wir das ganze Gewebe
Richtung Ohr gespannt.
Alles mit dem Ziel,
Frische
in das Gesicht reinzubringen.
So gewinnen Sie an Kinnlänge.
Das wirkt dann frischer.
Doch, das klingt gut.
Für den Moment bin ich glücklich.
Und danach noch glücklicher.
- Wunderbar.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Juli.
Sitz.
Pfötchen geben. Sehr gut.
Rollen.
Den Wunsch, die Augen operieren
zu lassen, habe ich schon lange.
Schon mit 40,
also sicher schon zehn Jahre lang.
Ich werde dieses Jahr 50 und finde,
das ist ein guter Zeitpunkt.
Ich will das machen.
Ich hätte sehr gerne einen Partner.
Aber es soll nicht einfach gut sein,
sondern sehr gut.
Sehr gut
und sonst lieber gar nicht.
Ich werde immer älter,
meine Augen sinken immer tiefer,
und ich möchte einem Partner
eine schöne Frau gönnen.
Ja.
Jetzt ist diese Haut hier unten.
Und nachher
soll sie wieder oben sein.
Wie ursprünglich.
V.a. dieses Gewicht hier ist ...
Das ist ziemlich viel Haut.
Es gab eine Zeit,
in der ich sehr viel weinte.
Bestimmt ein Jahr lang täglich.
Und zwar
aus einer extremen Tiefe heraus.
Mein Partner war gestorben.
Und ich trauerte sehr lange.
Ich machte damals
einen riesigen Fehler.
Ich nahm keine ...
Ich hätte die Augen kühlen sollen.
Aber ich tat es nicht und
manchmal wurden sie richtig heiss.
Sie wurden ganz geschwollen.
Ich hätte sie kühlen sollen.
Viel, viel später
sagte mir das jemand mal.
Wenn die Augen
die ganze Zeit anschwellen,
geht die Haut
irgendwann nicht mehr zurück.
Wir haben uns beide
sehr tief geliebt.
Und ...
Das war ein Teil von mir.
Ich hatte das erst einmal im Leben.
Wenn ich Glück habe,
gibt es das noch mal,
und sonst war es schön,
das erlebt haben zu dürfen.
Es ist wie eine Verschmelzung.
Man liest oder hört immer davon,
aber ich durfte das ...
Er war einfach mein Seelenpartner.
* Ruhige Streichklänge *
Hallo. Grüezi, Herr Häcki.
Guten Tag, freut mich sehr.
Sie dürfen gleich mitkommen.
Vielleicht können Sie mir
anhand des Spiegels genau sagen ...
Sie dürfen ihn selbst halten.
... was Ihnen auffällt,
welche Aspekte es sind,
die Sie stören.
Die Haut, die hier runterkommt,
drückt auf das Auge.
Wenn diese weg wäre,
dieser Streifen hier ...
... der runterdrückt.
Gibt es noch andere Dinge, die Sie,
wenn Sie in den Spiegel schauen,
lieber anders hätten?
Oder stimmt der Rest?
Ich sehe natürlich
eine alternde Frau,
eine Frau, die etwas älter wird,
aber ...
Mein Hauptfokus sind die Augen.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Klar, man könnte immer ...
Manchmal stört mich die Zornesfalte,
weil sie grob wirkt.
Man wirkt grob und ernst,
aber ich bin ein lustiger Mensch.
Ich mag es, Spass zu haben,
darum ist das manchmal etwas schade.
Das denke ich mir manchmal.
Solche Sachen halt.
Es ist auch nicht witzig, wenn man
Falten um den Mund herum kriegt.
Ich bin nicht verbissen.
Einerseits
wird die Haut etwas dünner
und das Ganze erschlafft etwas.
Und was man auch sieht:
Mit dem Alter geht
die Anzahl der Fettzellen zurück.
Auch der Knochen wird dünner,
die Haut wird dünner,
das ganze Volumen geht zurück.
Jetzt dürfen Sie mal
die Augen schliessen.
Genau. Ich lege das hier hinein.
Sie können sie öffnen.
Jetzt sehen Sie den Effekt ...
- Riesig.
... wenn wir die Oberlider straffen.
Wenn ich mit dem anderen vergleiche,
ist das ein Riesenunterschied.
Ja, es ist wieder normal.
Es ist so, wie es mal war.
Man kann sich auch wieder schminken.
Dann das Nächste - das Volumen
kann man auf zwei Arten aufbauen.
Die eine ist Hyaluronsäure,
die man spritzt.
Der Vorteil ist,
dass man es genau dosieren kann.
Sie sehen das Resultat sofort.
Der Nachteil ist,
dass es sich immer wieder abbaut.
Sie müssten dann jedes ...
Je nachdem, welche man nimmt,
müssten Sie immer wieder
nach einem halben Jahr, einem Jahr
oder eineinhalb Jahren vorbeikommen.
Die andere Möglichkeit
ist Eigenfett.
Irgendwo, wo Sie
eine kleine Problemzone haben,
entnimmt man etwas Fett,
verarbeitet es
und verteilt es vorsichtig in
der Zone, die man aufbauen möchte.
Von dem,
was Sie mir jetzt erzählt haben,
ist mir das Eigenfett
etwas sympathischer.
Man darf mir ansehen,
dass ich älter geworden bin,
dass ich etwas erlebt habe,
aber die Zeit des Weinens
ist vorbei.
(Baumann-Hölzle) Kann man
eine Lebensgeschichte abstreifen?
Das halte ich für Selbstbetrug.
Die Lebensgeschichte
kann man nicht abstreifen.
Sie ist ja auch ein Schatz.
Auch wenn viel Trauriges ...
Wir alle
haben Brüche in unserem Leben,
wir alle
hatten Schwierigkeiten im Leben
und haben Trauriges erlebt.
Am Schluss stellt sich die Frage:
Was ...
Was bedeutet es,
wenn man all das ausradiert?
Was ist das für ein Leben? Das Leben
ist doch dazu da, gelebt zu werden.
Ich lasse jedes halbe Jahr
mal was machen.
Wenn ich das Gefühl habe,
es sei wieder mal nötig.
Plasma ist ja
die Flüssigkeit des Blutes.
Darin haben wir ganz viele wichtige
regulative Proteine und Moleküle,
sog. Wachstumsfaktoren.
Diese haben wir konzentriert
mittels Zentrifugierung.
Wenn man sich
mit seiner Haut beschäftigt
und versucht, etwas zu machen,
dann steht das Needling oder
Vampirlifting, wie man das nennt,
ganz vorne, weil es eine
mittlerweile etablierte Methode ist,
der Hautalterung entgegenzuwirken.
Ich werden nächsten Monat
37 Jahre alt.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich
mein Alter nicht akzeptiere.
Sie sieht jetzt zwar aus wie ...
... massakriert, aber morgen
ist das schon wieder weg.
Mein Ziel ist es,
wenn ich in den Spiegel schaue,
mir selbst zu gefallen.
Es sind kleine Dinge,
die man mit kleinem Aufwand ...
... verbessern kann.
So.
Voilà.
- Danke.
Viele fragen mich ja: "Was haben Sie
schon gemacht? Wie alt sind Sie?"
Also ich ...
Ich kümmere mich ein bisschen
um meine Haut.
Mit Hormonkosmetik,
mit Hyaluronsäure
als feuchtigkeitsspendendes Molekül.
Ein bisschen Botox,
gerade im oberen Gesichtsbereich,
damit man dort nach wie vor
eine weiche Hautoberfläche behält.
Damit komme ich bislang klar.
Das reicht im Moment für mich.
* Ruhige Streichklänge *
Grüezi.
- Grüezi, Herr Häcki.
Alles klar?
- Danke. Bei Ihnen?
Gut, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie diesmal
einen besonderen Wunsch?
Ich habe einen etwas anderen Wunsch,
und zwar auf der Stirn.
Diese tiefe Falte soll etwas weg.
Und hier
bei den Mundwinkeln an der Seite.
Die Nasolabial-Falten?
Ich habe mir auch wegen des Kinns
Gedanken gemacht.
Ich bin mit dieser Form
noch nicht zufrieden.
Mit dem Kieferwinkel?
Hier unten? Klar.
Ist das Ziel,
das Männliche zu betonen?
Ja, genau.
In Ordnung?
- Wunderbar, danke.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
man sieht männlicher aus,
wenn man mehr Kanten im Gesicht hat.
Ich will mich im Spiegel anschauen
und sagen können:
"Ich bin jetzt attraktiver
als vorher."
Dadurch kann ich auch gegen aussen
selbstbewusster auftreten.
Ich versuche,
die Menschen zu verstehen,
aber das ist nicht
unbedingt zwingend.
Ich will sicherstellen,
dass sie nachher glücklicher sind.
Das ist meine Verantwortung.
Gut, dann mache ich jetzt
den Kieferwinkel.
Letztlich geht es bei Fillern immer
um die Differenz von Berg und Tal,
von mehr und weniger.
Man muss
die Unterschiede hervorheben.
Man sieht den Unterschied
recht deutlich.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Auch die Stirn.
Haben Sie es sich so vorgestellt?
- Genau.
Sehr gut. Besten Dank.
- Bitte.
(Baumann-Hölzle)
Die Oberfläche wird immer wichtiger.
Und das,
was unter der Oberfläche passiert,
fällt immer mehr aus dem Blick.
Die Frage ist:
Werden wir glücklich,
wenn wir uns rein
an Äusserlichkeiten orientieren?
Das bedeutet nicht, dass
das Äusserliche keine Rolle spielt.
Das macht es ja so schwierig.
Es spielt immer eine Rolle,
wenn wir ehrlich sind.
Schönheit ist immer ein Thema.
Aber Schönheit unterliegt Trends,
Modeerscheinungen.
Eine Rubensfigur ist
ein ganz anderes Schönheitsideal
als eine Twiggy.
Und all das ist natürlich sehr stark
gesamtgesellschaftlich geprägt.
Was mache ich als Person damit?
Ich komme nicht
aus diesem Sog heraus,
ich muss
auf bestimmte Weise verhalten.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ich war auch auf diesem Weg:
"Warum nicht Botox?"
"So kann man die Falten aufhalten."
Denn das ist es ja, was Botox macht.
Sie verschwinden nicht komplett.
Ich probierte es aus. Ich liess mir
die Zornesfalte spritzen.
Ich liess mir
die Krähenfüsse spritzen.
Wenn ich mir
Fotos von damals ansehe,
ist der Gesichtsausdruck
ziemlich verzerrt.
Und ich musste feststellen,
besonders in meinem Beruf,
dass ich Mimik brauche.
Was man spürt,
wenn man Botox spritzt:
Man kann es wirklich
nicht mehr bewegen.
Man gewöhnt sich zwar daran,
aber es geht nicht mehr.
Das ist ein schräges Gefühl -
als würde jemand hier festhalten.
Man merkt, es geht nicht mehr.
Und ...
Sobald das Botox nachlässt
und man merkt,
dass man das Gesicht wieder
bewegen kann, ist das wunderschön.
Eine Befreiung aus einem Korsett.
Mein Gesicht lebt wieder.
Ein Gesicht darf leben,
mit der ganzen Mimik.
Das ist wunderschön,
das ist ein Freiheitsgefühl.
Das spürte ich stark,
als ich mit Botox aufhörte.
Ich musste sagen:
Lebendigkeit im Gesicht
ist mir viel wichtiger
als irgendwelche Falten.
Das nennt sich Gesichtsyoga,
aber ich nenne es Gesichtstraining.
Man bekommt dadurch
ein natürliches Lifting.
Aber es ist eine Illusion,
zu denken,
dass damit die Falten weggehen.
Ich habe mich wahrscheinlich
für einen guten Weg entschieden.
Allein mit der Muskulatur,
die ich stärken konnte,
bildet sich eine gewisse Fülle, die
ein frisches Aussehen hervorbringt.
Es ist dieses Gefühl:
Ich tue mir selbst etwas Gutes.
Ich mache nicht etwas,
um etwas zu sein, das ich nicht bin.
Mich interessiert viel mehr,
wie ich mit anderen Menschen,
mit meinem Sohn umgegangen bin.
Das hat nicht viel
mit den Äusserlichkeiten zu tun.
Es ist schön, sich schön machen und
die Möglichkeiten nutzen zu dürfen.
Aber es definiert mich nicht.
Die Menschen schauen einen an
und man ist auch ein Vorbild.
Wenn man sich einfach gehen lässt
und irgendwie mit Dreitagebart
den coolen Typen spielen will
und sich vielleicht
auch nicht so sehr pflegt,
und wenn auch
die Mitarbeiter so rumlaufen,
dann ist man am falschen Ort.
Ich treibe etwas Sport,
ich achte auf die Ernährung,
wenig Kohlenhydrate, nicht
so viel Alkohol, ich rauche nicht.
Ich achte darauf, dass ich
immer 7-8 Std. Schlaf kriege.
Solche Dinge sind sehr wichtig.
Ab und zu mache ich etwas Botox
oder auch Hyaluronsäure.
Aber bei uns
sehen alle natürlich aus,
wie es in der Schweiz normal ist.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Hallo.
Grüezi, hier ist die Lucerne Clinic,
Lidija Sucur.
Viele Menschen
sind verbittert über ihr Leben.
Ich nicht, wirklich nicht.
Ich fühle mich frei,
kann tun und lassen, was ich will.
Es ist einfach ein gutes Leben.
* Der Herzmonitor piept. *
Die Linie war praktisch
hinter dem Kieferwinkel.
Jetzt ist sie über dem Kieferwinkel.
Der ganze Gewebeblock hat sich
in diese Richtung entwickelt.
Das, was vorher hier dran war,
bedeckt fast das ganze Ohr,
ohne dass ich ziehen muss.
Diesen Überschuss nehmen wir weg.
Man hört gar nicht so selten,
dass Leute, die zu einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt anfangen,
mit welcher Behandlung auch immer,
dann, wenn es genau die Probleme,
die sie für sich haben, löst,
sagen: "Mensch, das hätte ich
schon früher wissen sollen."
"Dann hätte ich mir
nicht so viele Sorgen machen müssen
oder mich nicht so aus meinem
Lebensumfeld zurückziehen müssen."
Ich mache gerne Kopfsachen,
wie wir es nennen.
Also das, was wir hier machen:
Augenlidkorrekturen,
Nasenkorrekturen,
Ohrenkorrekturen.
Das ist das ...
Es gibt nicht
eine bestimmte Operation,
von der ich sage,
dass ich sie am liebsten mache
und am besten jeden Tag.
Ich finde es schön, dass ich
eine gewisse Abwechslung haben kann.
* Helle Klänge *
(Baumann-Hölzle) Die Frage ist:
Was passiert danach,
nach einer Schönheitsoperation?
Verhilft sie mir danach wirklich
zu einem gelungenen Leben,
zu tieferen Beziehungen?
Ist es wirklich das richtige Mittel?
Das ist am Ende die Frage.
Zu welchem Zweck ist es ein Mittel?
Ist der Zweck ein gelungenes Leben?
Ist er ...
Ist er Glück?
Diese Abklärung des Lebensziels
ist ganz wichtig,
bevor ich
eine Schönheitsoperation mache.
Was will ich eigentlich
von meinem Leben?
Was trägt diese Schönheitsoperation
tatsächlich zu meinem Leben bei?
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist meine Zauberbrille.
Die ist super.
Gut.
Genau, schliessen Sie die Augen.
Geht es?
- Mhm.
Sie machen das sehr gut.
Am Anfang ist es etwas geschwollen,
aber danach ist es ganz dezent.
Niemand wird denken,
dass Sie etwas haben machen lassen.
Ich zeichne die Stellen ein,
wo etwas Eigenfett hinkommt.
Einerseits hier.
Ich werde vielleicht
ein paar Jahre jünger aussehen,
aber ich werde
nicht weniger reif sein.
Die Reife, die ich jetzt habe,
die bleibt.
Ich bin gegen den Begriff
Schönheitschirurgie.
Ich bin kein Schönheitschirurg.
Den Menschen geht es nicht darum,
schön sein zu wollen.
Sie wollen sich wohlfühlen,
glücklich sein.
Wir machen Menschen glücklich.
Ich denke,
Glück findet man sowieso nicht.
Das ist nicht etwas, das wir haben.
Glück ist etwas, das wir erleben.
Glück ist etwas, das sich zeigt ...
... in einem schönen Augenblick.
Sei es, wenn ich die Natur bestaune
oder bei einer Begegnung,
die mich erfüllt.
Dabei passiert
beim Aussehen sehr viel.
Dann kann ein Gesicht, das ich
vielleicht nicht so schön finde,
eine unglaubliche Schönheit
entfalten.
(Häcki) Viele Patienten
sind vor der Operation nervös.
Um die Zeit im Operationssaal
möglichst angenehm zu machen,
fragen wir,
ob sie eine Lieblingsmusik haben,
die wir spielen dürfen.
* "Dr Schacher Seppli"
von Ruedi Rymann wird gespielt. *
# ... grad näb en ärmste Maa.
# Ah je, dä muess as gliich Ort he.
Spüren Sie schon etwas?
- Ja, ja.
# ... verlassne Lüüt ...
- Super.
# ... müends schön im Himmel ha.
Ich komme dann wieder.
* Sanfte Musik, Herzmonitor *
Ich muss nicht
viel Verschiedenes machen.
Ich könnte den ganzen Tag
Brustvergrösserungen machen
und wäre zufrieden,
denn jede Person ist wieder anders.
Warum muss man so zufrieden sein,
wie man ist?
Man darf, aber man muss nicht.
Man darf etwas verändern.
Man darf lange Haare tragen,
wenn einem das besser gefällt.
In unserer Gesellschaft
haben wir diese Möglichkeiten.
Ich habe überall schön infiltriert.
Jetzt entnehmen wir
hier unten etwas Fett.
Ich mache
kein klassisches Fettabsaugen,
sondern ich will möglichst viele,
noch lebendige Fettzellen entnehmen,
damit diese im Gesicht
wieder anwachsen können.
Ich habe eine ganz dünne Kanüle
mit kleinen Löchern.
* Herzmonitor *
* Leises Gespräch *
Das Fett
muss noch verarbeitet werden.
Sie müssen ruhig sein.
Wenn Sie den Mund bewegen,
bewegt sich das ganze Gesicht.
Bei diesem Eingriff
lasse ich die Patienten
zwischendurch kurz aufwachen.
Schauen Sie, Frau Bucher.
Sie dürfen die Augen mal öffnen,
bitte.
Weit öffnen. Noch mehr.
Noch etwas.
Gut, wieder schliessen.
Fest schliessen.
Mir ist egal, was andere denken.
Wenn man nur
ästhetische Eingriffe anbietet,
muss einem das egal sein,
denn sehr viele finden das blöd.
Man muss einfach am Abend
ins Bett gehen und sagen können:
"Was ich mache, ist gut.
Ich kann dahinterstehen, es stimmt."
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Frau Bucher.
- Hallo, guten Tag.
Wie geht es?
- Super.
Ja?
Bis jetzt bin ich happy.
Ich nehme die Maske weg.
Diese Spezialmaske
kühlt genau auf 17 °C.
Denn bei 17 °C ist der Lymphabfluss
noch gewährleistet.
Okay.
Wir haben hier
einen Spiegel für Sie.
Oh, ich freue mich.
Nehmen Sie ihn in die Hand?
Das ist die richtige Seite.
- Nicht die Vergrösserung!
Sonst sehe ich aus wie ein Fisch.
Drei, zwei, eins.
Oh.
Ich bin blass.
Aber ich muss die Augen anschauen.
Ja, super.
Das wird noch abschwellen, nicht?
Ein bisschen,
aber es hat nicht stark geblutet.
Ich habe mir mehr vorgestellt.
Mhm.
Sie haben
ziemlich viel weggeschnitten.
Nicht zu viel, nicht zu wenig.
- Aber es war viel Haut.
Es war einiges.
Wie lange hält das?
Noch das ganze Leben?
Nichts hält ewig,
denn die Alterung schreitet voran.
Aber es wird nie mehr so sein
wie vorher. Auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das liebe ich an meinem Beruf,
Frau Bucher:
Wenn ich die Freude der Menschen
danach sehe.
Mhm.
Ich muss noch etwas ...
- Schön?- Ja.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Klopfen *
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Hallo, Frau Müller.
Wie geht es?
- Danke, sehr gut.
Haben Sie die Nacht gut verbracht?
Konnten Sie ein bisschen schlafen?
Ja, allerdings
nicht die ganze Nacht.
Wie ist es mit den Schmerzen?
- Ich merke gar nichts.
Gar nichts? Das ist ja schön.
Ja.
Wir schauen mal unter den Verband.
Wir werden ihn jetzt entfernen
und besprechen, wie es weitergeht.
Ich habe Ihnen ja
von der Bandage erzählt,
die sie zu Hause
noch eine Woche tragen.
Das sieht alles sehr schön aus.
Hier haben Sie einen Spiegel.
Sie können mal schauen.
Die Halskontur ist genau so,
wie sie sein soll.
Super.
Das freut mich.
Hier haben wir es voller gemacht.
Es ist leicht geschwollen.
Das wird noch besser werden.
Ich bin jetzt schon sehr zufrieden.
Wenn dann
die blauen Flecken weg sind,
habe ich das Gefühl ...
Ich werde es keine Minute bereuen,
das getan zu haben.
* Spannungsvolle
elektronische Musik *
Ich habe drei kleine Kinder
und ein grosses.
Und ich denke ...
Man will frisch und jung aussehen,
wenn man so kleine Kinder hat.
Sonst denken die anderen,
man sei die Grossmutter.
Ich wurde durch Caroline
dazu ermutigt.
Sie ist meine Schwägerin
und ist mit mir hierhergekommen.
Mein Mann sagt,
ich sei eine riesige Baustelle.
Er müsse sich ein Jüngere suchen.
(Lachend) Als das mit den ...
Nein, das war Spass.
Aber er hat es wirklich gesagt.
Er hält es nicht für nötig,
aber er findet es okay.
An älteren Frauen muss man
einfach viel mehr machen.
Ich musste nach den Kindern
auch eine Brustoperation machen.
Damals musste er dann eben zahlen.
Das ist ...
Das hat damit zu tun.
Aber er hat es gerne getan.
Ich hoffe,
dass ich mir nachher besser gefalle,
dass ich mich mehr liebhabe.
* Spannungsvolle
elektronische Musik *
Bei Botox ist es sinnvoll,
früh damit anzufangen.
Je früher man anfängt,
desto besser ist der Effekt,
dass sich die Falten
gar nicht erst stark entwickeln.
Deswegen kann man es
grundsätzlich empfehlen.
Ob das mit Mitte 20
oder Mitte 30 sein soll,
hängt
von individuellen Strukturen ab:
Wie ist die Haut?
Wie ist die Faltenbildung?
Ich kann aussen
auch noch etwas machen.
Nein, ist gut.
- Ja?
Es sieht symmetrisch aus.
Die Oberlippe ist grösser geworden.
Mir gefällt es.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall
viel besser aus.
(Baumann-Hölzle) Es steckt auch
eine gewisse Tragik dahinter.
Wenn ich mich selbst
nicht lieben kann,
so wie ich aussehe,
wie ich auf die Welt gekommen bin.
Wenn ich mich
grundlegend verändern muss,
Risiken eingehen muss,
damit ich anders aussehe.
Ich bin nicht nur Körper
oder nur Psyche.
Das ist eine Einheit.
Die Faszination eines Menschen,
der vom Leben gezeichnet ist,
der Ausstrahlung hat,
das ist etwas ganz anderes
als ein Botox-Gesicht.
Mit diesem Menschen
will ich eine Beziehung eingehen.
Beim Botox-Gesicht
brauche ich viel mehr Energie,
um mit dieser Person ...
Es fällt mir selbst auf: "Hat sie
irgendwas machen lassen oder nicht?"
Dann kommt jemand mit dieser Stirn
und ich denke: "Hä?"
Ja.
Am Ende ist es
eine Frage der Beziehung.
Machen wir sie
von der Äusserlichkeit abhängig
oder sind wir überhaupt noch bereit,
uns aufeinander einzulassen?
Auch auf mich selbst einzulassen.
(Häcki) Wenn es darum geht,
Alterserscheinungen zu minimieren,
ist das ein laufender Prozess.
Das heisst, sie kommen immer wieder.
Einige kommen jedes Jahr,
andere alle paar Monate.
Nachdem ich es ausprobiert hatte,
wurde meine Ausstrahlung
ganz anders.
Ich fühle mich ganz anders.
Mein Lachen und das ganze Gesicht
wirken anders.
Ich höre von anderen,
dass ich entspannter aussehe.
Es hat also eine Wirkung auf sie.
Frau Buerli, guten Morgen.
- Herr Häcki.
Freut mich, Sie zu sehen.
- Geht es Ihnen gut?
Gehen wir rein.
Bitte kommen Sie mit.
Zuerst spritze ich
das Botulinumtoxin.
Dann kommt die Zornesfalte,
sodass Sie diese
gar nicht mehr bewegen können.
Bei der Stirn sagten Sie,
glaube ich,
dass Sie
doch noch etwas Mimik wollen?
Nur abschwächen?
- Genau. So ist es richtig.
Mit dem Thema Alter
habe ich gar kein Problem.
Im Gegenteil.
Ich finde, man wird immer weiser.
Man weiss, was man will,
und hat eine andere Ausstrahlung.
Es kommt immer darauf an,
wie sich ein Mensch entwickelt.
Aber ich habe kein Problem.
Ich gebe mich so, wie ich bin.
(Baumann-Hölzle) Wir haben
ein Problem mit dem Älterwerden,
weil wir
die Vergänglichkeit ausblenden.
Ich verschenke damit
natürlich auch die Möglichkeit,
mich mit dem Prozess der
Vergänglichkeit auseinanderzusetzen.
Dieser Prozess
ist nicht immer angenehm.
Das will ich
auch gar nicht behaupten.
Dieser Prozess
hat viel mit Loslassen zu tun.
Das Loslassen gehört dazu.
Ich muss mein Aussehen
als junge Frau loslassen können.
Ich muss mich fragen,
wie meine Identität jetzt aussieht.
Aber dieser Prozess bereitet mich
letztlich auch auf das Sterben vor.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Jetzt sind Sie gespannt, nicht?
Diese Schwellung
legt sich dann wieder etwas?
Absolut.
Schön.
- Es ist sehr dezent.
Man wird es nicht merken.
Ich massiere es etwas.
* Dynamische, helle Musik *
Wir haben eine Studie gemacht
über den Effekt von Botox
jenseits des Gesichtsglättens.
Der Grund für diese Studie war,
dass es Theorien
im Bereich der Embodied Emotions
oder Embodied Cognition gibt,
die besagen, dass wir erstens
Emotionen, die uns begegnen,
in uns selbst simulieren.
Wir spiegeln die Emotionen,
die uns in der Aussenwelt begegnen.
Das ist natürlich
niemals so ausgeprägt,
dass wir genau das Gleiche zeigen,
aber wir zeigen es in Ansätzen.
Unser Gehirn
verarbeitet diese Information,
die wir
von unseren Muskeln bekommen,
und das hilft uns dabei,
Emotionen besser zu verstehen,
zu kategorisieren, zu verarbeiten.
Aber Botox blockiert
genau diese Mimik-Muskeln.
Dieses Blockieren der Muskeln zeigt,
in unserer Studie zumindest,
dass es auch
einen Nebeneffekt haben kann.
Dieser Nebeneffekt ist,
dass es schwierig wird,
Emotionen aus unserer Umwelt,
die nicht sehr ausgeprägt sind,
richtig oder zumindest
sehr schnell zu verstehen.
Das wünschen wir uns ja nicht, wenn
wir eine Botox-Behandlung machen.
Ich sehe diese Studien
eher im akademischen Bereich.
Das sind sicher wissenschaftlich
fundierte Ergebnisse,
die Frage ist aber:
Was bedeutet das für den Alltag,
wenn die emotionale Empfindung
ein bisschen verlangsamt ist?
Ist das etwas,
das ich im Alltag spüre?
Oder etwas,
das man bei anderen spürt?
Frau Bucher, guten Morgen.
Geht es Ihnen gut?
- Tipptopp, super.
Ihnen auch?
- Danke.
Gehen wir rein?
Drei Monate sind vorbei.
Wie war es für Sie?
- Super.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Ich hatte wirklich keine Probleme.
Das Einzige waren Rückenschmerzen.
- Okay.
Wegen des Fettabsaugens.
Man sieht es sehr schön:
Die Augenlider kamen
auf beiden Seiten schräg runter.
Hier etwas mehr als dort.
Jetzt ist es symmetrisch,
man sieht das Augenlid wieder.
Die Tränenrinne
ist schön aufgefüllt.
Und hier haben wir mit Eigenfett
das Volumen aufgefüllt.
Ich finde ...
Es sieht sehr gut aus. Man sieht
Ihnen an, dass Sie sich wohlfühlen.
Ich bin eigentlich nicht jung,
ich werde am Freitag 50.
Aber irgendwie fühle ich mich jung.
Natürlich nicht die ganze Zeit.
Es gibt auch Momente,
in denen es nicht so ist.
Aber es geht mir gut
und ich bin gesund.
Ich bin aktiv.
Ich habe ein gutes Leben.
Von daher fühle ich mich jung -
jung geblieben.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
So.
Ich begrüsse Sie.
Wenn Sie mitkommen wollen.
So, Frau Müller. Wie geht's?
Vier Monate
sind seit der OP vergangen.
Sehr gut.
Beschwerden, Schmerzen?
- Gar nichts.
Es heisst ja,
man müsse nach der Behandlung
einige Schmerzen aushalten,
aber ich habe gar nichts gespürt.
Gar nichts?
- Gar nichts.
Wir haben ja das Gefühl ...
Es ist insgesamt
sehr viel besser geworden,
aber es bleibt etwas
von der Hautalterung zurück.
Das ist eigentlich normal.
Aber wir haben ja hohe Ansprüche
und wollen dort natürlich
das Optimum rausholen.
Nadeln, 24 Stück.
Wir können einstellen,
wie weit sie rauskommen sollen.
Wir fangen mit 1 mm an,
2 mm oder 3 mm.
Sie sorgen
für eine Kollagenstimulation
und verursachen eine Schrumpfung.
Ich denke nicht
an meine Vergänglichkeit.
Andere Menschen
haben stets den Tod vor Augen:
"Ich habe nicht mehr viel Zeit."
Daran denke ich gar nicht.
Bei Udo Jürgens war es ähnlich.
Einige Monate vor seinem Tod hatte
er noch einen grossen Auftritt,
und plötzlich beim Spaziergang
am Bodensee ist er tot umgefallen.
Es kommt, wie es kommt.
Und so gehe ich auch durchs Leben.
Wenn ich mit anderen vergleiche,
die in diesem Alter sind
und die nichts machen,
denen es relativ egal ist,
wie sie aussehen ...
Es gibt ja Menschen,
denen das alles ziemlich egal ist.
Ich war schon immer
eine Ästhetikerin.
Mein Alltag ist durch das hier
viel besser geworden.
Ich freue mich,
dass ich es getan habe,
dass ich mir wieder gefalle.
Vorher habe ich mir
nicht mehr gefallen.
Ja.
# Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday, liebe Anita.
Wenn ich mich jetzt aus
diesem Leben verabschieden müsste,
könnte ich sagen:
"Wow, ich hatte ein tolles Leben."
Ich konnte ich selbst sein.
* Schiefe Bläserversion
von "Happy Birthday" *
Der Richtige
ist noch nicht gekommen.
Liebe Kamera!
Sie ist auch noch Single.
Hey!
Nein, das wird gelöscht.
Aber ...
Ich hoffe, dass der Richtige
nicht nur wegen der Augen kommt.
Wenn sich ein Mensch wohlfühlt ...
Wobei du dich immer
wohlgefühlt hast. Aber, ja.
* Fröhliche Drehorgelmusik *
Mein Empfinden jetzt
im Vergleich zu früher ist,
dass ich mich viel freier fühle.
Ich bin wieder lustiger,
weil ich wieder mehr Mimik habe.
Das Leben war zwar vorher schon da,
aber jetzt ist es
wieder frischer geworden.
Ich habe nicht mehr dauernd
Kopfschmerzen,
ich kann wieder
mit den Augen sprechen.
Es ist positiver.
Es heisst ja, man habe
keinen Einfluss auf das Gesicht,
mit dem man geboren wird.
Aber man hat grossen Einfluss
auf das Gesicht, mit dem man stirbt.
Das war früher nicht
an die Schönheitschirurgie gebunden.
Sondern an das Leben selbst.
Aber auch damals
gab es die Illusion,
dass wir alles ...
... kontrollieren können.
Je mehr wir
verbissen an etwas festhalten ...
umso weniger leben wir.
Was ist am Ende das Ziel des Lebens?
Eine schöne Visage
oder ein gelebtes Leben?
Das heisst aber nicht,
dass wir uns nicht darum bemühen,
uns ästhetisch ...
... zu pflegen.
Überhaupt, uns zu pflegen.
Einander ...
Sich füreinander schön zu machen.
Aber das ist etwas ganz anderes
als diese Selbstoptimierung.
* Sanfte, beschwingte Klaviermusik *
Danke schön.
- Bitte schön.
So.
- Wunderbar.
Jetzt gibt es doch noch
einen Jahrmarkt.
In Illnau. Trotz Corona.
- Gibt es noch einen?
Aber in Wetzikon nicht?
- Nein.
Nirgends, nur in Illnau.
Am Wochenende. Wir könnten hingehen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2021